I don't know; I'm a newcomer here
and I would like to know what
is it? Is this a lecture or a seminar?
I would like to understand it better.
If you could explain it to me.
More like a symposium, a
discussion or a lecture?
I mean it depends upon you.
Ladies and gentlemen, listen to me.
It's a combination.
Let me, I will
perhaps make a compromise
that I would lecture but
you have a right – and I would rather
appreciate – if you would interrupt my
lecture in case you have a question about it.
This is my policy.
I’ve been a teacher for many, many years.
My policy is
that the students interrupt me if
they want to ask me a question.
So I would appreciate if you should
interrupt me if something is not clear or
you have a question or if you
disagree with me.
Philosophy of religion has many levels.
Modern philosophy of religion,
comparative philosophy of religion,
medieval philosophers, Jewish and
Christian, and so forth, and so on.
My training basically was not
in the field of philosophy of
religion, but philosophy of science.
Something new that came to philosophy.
But perhaps I have a strange
approach to philosophy of religion.
As my training was not a theological
one or exclusively
in the field of philosophy of
religion, of religious thought.
However, I have been, so to say,
testing or thrusting, using an
expression by Heidegger, into a
certain environment where philosophy
of religion was considered important.
So I started to… I tried to interpret it
– Jewish religious concepts –
in philosophical terms.
To tell you that I know much
about it, I would not be sincere.
Basically, I am very perplexed,
perhaps as perplexed as
anybody else and more.
And I don’t believe that
Judaism is a philosophy
or is a religion which has many
answers, like the Catholic philosophy.
Judaism has many problems but
very few answers, very few.
And perhaps the more I
lecture, the more perplexed
you will be and the more, I would
say, confused, instead of clearing
up some problems in your mind.
But it is good if you can see a problem
and to understand the
problem is insoluble,
and actually Maimonides says that to be
perplexed does not mean to be confused.
And whatever I will say, I
am not laying claim to any
theoretical or cognitive validity.
I don’t know whether what I’m
going to say is true or not.
It’s hard to say.
We don’t have criteria by which objectively
to judge our opinions about Judaism.
We have no laboratory, we have no tests.
The empirical approach we have is
just, I wouldn’t say has developed
as in the field of positive sciences.
All I will say to you is just
my own subjective thoughts
and feelings about Judaism.
I have tried to interpret
Judaism in modern terms,
for the Jew in his encounter
with the modern world.
I’ve tried very hard.
But it’s always subjective
experience and a subjective
interpretation on my part.
I am not out to convert anybody.
I am not carrying the gospel of Judaism.
I lack missionary zeal.
Whatever I will do, take it as an
act of confidence on my part, of,
as confessing, or rather letting
you share my own subjective
experience, my own private experience.
If you should find that my experience
and yours, there is some commensurability
between your feelings and my
experience, my efforts will be rewarded.
However, if you should find that my
experience and your experience are
incommensurable, incongruous, and
you disagree with me totally, I will
not feel hurt.
For it’s very hard to find
commensurability between private,
between private experiences
of two different individuals.
With the trait of uniqueness,
actually, excludes commensurability.
In general, whenever, whoever speaks about
Judaism and makes an authoritative
statement, I don’t believe – I’m not
saying about Jewish law, but about
Jewish philosophy – he is wrong.
It’s just a subjective interpretation.
We have no authority to determine
which philosophy is a perennial
Jewish philosophy, and which
one is just a modern, transient
interpretation of Judaism.
Now, I believe that the topic of
our lectures will deal with man and
his social institutions he created.
But today I wouldn’t speak about
man, I’ll just give an introduction
as to the methodology of Judaism and
how we can approach this problem.
Judaism has a doctrine of man.
Because if it has no doctrine of
man, so we could get up and go home.
As a matter of fact, such a doctrine
underlies every civilized religion.
Any civilized religion, not only
Judaism, Christianity and Islam,
must have a doctrine of man.
Since religion is concerned with
the relationship – with the triple
relationship – of God, man, and the
world [this is the basic relationship
in any philosophy of religion] it must
necessarily possess some knowledge on
the one hand of God’s infinite will,
which conveys to man the moral law and
the means by which this moral law is
to be realized, and on the other hand
of man himself, the subject of the good
religious conduct and the ethical norms.
Now let me add something.
Cognition or knowledge is one of
the main motifs which determine
and shape the religious experience.
The homo religiosus,
in technical terms, means a
man of religious experience.
The homo religiosus is engaged
in a cognitive gesture.
He is basically a theoretical man.
The homo theoreticus,
or anthropos theoreticus.
The intellectual urge is as
potent in him as it is in the
homo theoreticus.
Curiosity prompts both the homo religiosus
and the homo theoreticus to face the world
and man in an inquisitive mood of inquiry.
I am saying that because many
theorists in the history of philosophy
of religion have maintained that
religion is not a cognitive gesture.
Either Schleiermacher, who wanted
us to believe in emotional gesture
and the main experience of the homo
religiosus can be reduced to the
feeling of absolute dependence.
Or as Kant and the Neo-Kantian school
maintained, the religious experience is
an ethical one, a moral experience, the
experience of the absolute imperative.
So Schleiermacher sentimentalized
religion, Kant ethicized it.
Both of them have eliminated the
intellectual urge of the homo religiosus.
The homo religiosus doesn’t want to know,
but he wants to act, says Kant.
Schleiermacher said, the homo
religiosus doesn’t want to
know, nor does he want to act.
He feels something.
He is emotionally unique.
However, intellectually, volitionally,
ethically, morally, there is no uniqueness
to him, no singularity.
However, it’s impossible
to maintain this attitude,
particularly in modern religion.
The religious experience has basic,
central, intellectual, or cognitive motifs.
Like the homo theoreticus, whoever
he is – scientist, psychologist,
philosopher – the religious person is
a person who seeks knowledge.
Of course,
the objectives and hence the methods
of the homo religiosus and the
homo theoreticus are different.
They vary.
The homo theoreticus studies a
reality bounded in by finitude.
That’s all.
He does not know of any other reality.
Finitude and reality are identical for
him, whose multifarious complexities are
reduced, or can be reduced, to relational,
formal, mathematical equations, and to a
system of a dynamic interdependence,
whose rationale, the rationale of
reality – and science must believe
in the rationale of reality, because
otherwise the scientist would never
approach reality in a confident mood.
There is a rationale in reality
whose rationale manifests
itself in expressibility and
technological applicability.
This is the approach on the part
of the scientist to reality.
The homo religiosus explores
being at a different level.
Not so much for the sake of
discovering the here and now knowable,
explainable, and useful aspects.
He’s also interested in that, but his main
interest centers on something else.
He is not so much interested in the
knowledge of reality which is accessible
to us, but he is more interested in
transcending the charted lanes of an
orderly and neatly arranged cosmos
or universe, and venturing into
into the unknown, into remote, empty
distances and boundless stretches,
into a strange and puzzling and
baffling world, which can neither be
mathematized nor interpreted in
abstract constructs and concepts.
Because for the homo theoreticus, the total equation of the universe is knowable.
Of course, if the universe were not
knowable, comprehensible, there
would be actually a gesture of
resignation on the part of the
scientist or the homo theoreticus.
The equation, the total
equation of the homo religiosus
says “existence is a paradoxical affair,
a mysterium magnum, which
inspires in the man awe and tremor”.
Of course, ladies and gentlemen, in order
to arrive at such an absurd equation,
or if I may use Kierkegaard’s expression,
to perform the movement of resignation
which is basic for the homo religiosus,
homo religiosus must resign from
time to time in order to perform
the act or the movement of complete
resignation, the homo religiosus must
explore every nook and corner of reality;
examine, search every aspect of
being, and try to interpret even
the minutest process in reality.
Because the act of resignation on
the part of the homo religiosus is
not to be equated with the naivete
of the uninitiated, ignorant person
who denies the worth of knowledge
because he doesn’t know anything.
Not to be equated.
Whoever the homo religiosus is, he must
not be an ignorant person, nor must he be
an arrogant person.
Ignorance and arrogance are certain traits
which are completely, are strange to
the religious experience, incommensurate
with the religious awareness.
This skepticism which flows from an
arrogant attitude
is alien to the homo religiosus.
The act of resignation on the part of the
homo religiosus is rather to be compared
with the skepsis of the Ecclesiastes,
or the despair of Faust by Goethe,
who because of having
attained great intellectual heights,
because of their incessant drinking
from the fountainhead of wisdom
and their mastery of the cognitive
gesture and their insatiable curiosity,
have arrived at the conclusion that
being is an insoluble equation.
But it is a resignation which
follows knowledge and completes
the act of knowing, not an act of
resignation which precludes knowledge.
Because to resign before one
knows is not resignation.
This is arrogance and ignorance.
Of course, only the mathematician
can prove that certain
equations are insoluble.
A person who is not initiated in
mathematics cannot prove that.
And the homo religiosus is the
mathematician who tries to prove,
who feels that the total equation
of reality is an insoluble one.
Perhaps a great mystery.
But he is a man of knowledge.
He is an intellectual.
He is driven by the so-called,
if I may use a Kantian expression,
the metaphysical impulse.
He wants to know.
Not only wants to act, not only he
feels differently, he wants to know.
And of course the homo religiosus knows
of and is concerned with and is
guided by and exists by existential
purposes which surpass the
boundary lines of finitude, true.
He is also in another respect
different from the scientist.
The scientist studies only reality
which is bounded in by finitude, by the
frames of reference of time and space.
However, the homo religiosus knows
of another existence – I wouldn’t say
another existence because this would
sound a little too theological – but of an
existence which transcends the boundaries
of finitude and the boundaries of finitude
which is conditioned by temporality.
Yet, irrespective of the ultimate
end which religion pursues, and
which is above and outside the
worldly ambitions and aspirations of
the homo theoreticus, irrespective
of that, the drama of religion
unfolds only within the confines of
our natural orders, it means within
the confines of this worldliness.
Right here and now – and this is basically
Jewish – Right here and now, in a
world of sound and color, of sensuous
complexities, of change and development,
of mechanical motion and unalterable
processes, the homo man has his
rendezvous with infinity, with God.
In order to meet God, one does not
have to transcend this world, although,
perhaps, he knows of a higher existence.
But meeting God, and this is basically
Jewish – Perhaps Christianity will
disagree, I would say medieval
Christianity in this respect, we
will come later to this point, we
will return to this point – the
Jewish opinion always said that
one meets God right here and now,
within the confines of time and space.
Here and now, in the midst of the
event of a world of events and things,
of mechanical orders, man rises to
great heights and meets his creator,
and he also falls into bottomless abyss of
sin and actually inferior existence.
Right here and now, he rebels
against God and His authority which
he accepted prior to his rebellion.
And right here and now, he returns
to God meekly and humbly, like a
child who apologizes to his father
against whom he rebelled a while ago.
But it’s in the right
here and now reality.
Right here and now, man struggles
with absurdity and insensateness and
tries to infuse meaning into something
unknown which we call existence.
If, of course gentlemen, theater
of religious activities, of self,
of religious self-expression and
self-realization is to be found here in
our sensuous world, then understanding
of and acquaintanceship with the latter
– with this world – is a conditio sine qua
non for the proper guiding, for the proper
realization of our religious destiny.
So it means, what I wanted to say,
is that religion lays claims to knowledge;
and this knowledge does not pertain
to eternity or to some transcendental
entities or to some spiritual beings,
but religion wants to know this world,
this corporeal, sensuous world in all
its manifestations and at all its levels.
Like the scientist or
the homo theoreticus.
And of course, ladies and
gentlemen, it is a truism that
although the cognitive gesture of the homo
religiosus is a comprehensive one, aiming
at reality in its entirety, manifesting
itself in a variety of orders, the homo
religiosus is mainly concerned with the
order of personal existence.
Or to be more exact, with himself.
Of course, he wants to
know the world, certainly.
No doubt about it.
But he is more concerned with himself.
Perhaps there is a distinction between the
homo theoreticus and the homo religiosus.
The homo theoreticus until
recently, actually, was more
concerned with the outside world,
with the physical processes, with
motion, since the days of Thales.
He was more concerned with organic matter,
with the process of life, which
also belongs to the outside world.
He was less concerned with
himself, the scientist.
Because simply, if the scientist had
been concerned with himself as much
as he was concerned with the outside
world, with dead matter and inanimate
matter, then perhaps psychology
and sociology, all the humanities
would have progressed much more.
Because actually, knowledge of man is
a latecomer in the history of science.
It’s a newcomer actually.
All right.
In the history of philosophy, you know,
Socrates said, what is man?
But it was a different approach.
It was not knowledge,
theoretical knowledge.
It was more a practical problem.
What should man do in order to be happy?
This was the general problem
of the Greek philosophers.
Not who is man, what is man, what is
the existential experience, what kind of
a being he is, what is his uniqueness,
singularity, his station in the world,
in the universe, his struggle with the
outside world and struggle with himself.
No, this was not a problem of Socrates,
nor was it the problem of Aristotle or
his master Plato, nor was it the problem
of the Stoics and the Epicurean school.
The problem was a practical one, a
pragmatic one, a functional problem.
How can men be happy?
How can they attain eudaimonia or
what they called it pleasure, hedone?
It’s a practical problem.
And the whole discussion about man
in Greek philosophy, in the late
antiquity, in the Greek philosophy
from Socrates on down, so it did not
revolve about the metaphysic of man or
theory of man, it was more revolving
about the practical discipline of man.
How can man be happy?
It’s a technological problem about
man, not a theoretical problem.
And you know very well that
technological problems cannot be
solved unless you do basic research.
And this was the trouble with
the Greek philosophers.
When it came to the outside
world, they were pure theoreticians.
The pragmatic view absolutely
did not interest them at all.
They wanted to understand
for the sake of knowledge.
Of course, you know, the idea of
technology was alien to the Greek.
Completely alien, because
the type of knowledge he was
pursuing did not lend itself
to technological application.
However, when it came to man himself,
he suddenly turned into a technician.
Not who is man, what is man, but how
should man act in order to be happy.
And of course, the homo
religiosus is concerned with
man, and he has a double problem.
Who is man, and also the old Greek
problem, the pragmatic problem,
what shall a man do in order
to find self-fulfillment.
Religion must possess intimate
knowledge and understanding at all
levels of the existential experience
or what you call self-awareness.
Otherwise, the God-man relationship could
remain an enigma to the homo religiosus.
If he doesn’t understand
himself, how can he approach God?
However
universally true the aforementioned
maxim is, that the homo religiosus is
an intellectual type and is particularly
interested in self-knowledge, it is
true, various religions differ as to
the manner in which they emphasize
the above-mentioned cognitive
aspects of the homo religiosus.
While
most religious systems, and I am speaking,
when I say most religious systems, I
am referring to occidental religion.
I have very little knowledge
of oriental religion.
I have no right to speak,
not even to mention it.
Occidental religion I understand,
Christianity and Islam.
I am quite well acquainted with
Christian scholastics, modern.
Most religious systems were more prone to
theological thinking and developed
theosophic doctrines, focusing their
attention upon transcendental reality.
And they developed only latent
religious anthropologies.
I mean, to distinguish it from
scientific anthropology, we
call religious anthropology.
When I say religious anthropology,
it means the metaphysic of
man, the interpretation of
man formulated in religious terms.
For instance, in Christianity, they have
a social philosophy, no doubt about it.
Thomas Aquinas developed quite an
extensive social philosophy based upon
natural law, lex naturalis or lex naturae.
But however, it’s funny, it’s strange,
they developed a social philosophy
without inquiring into the essence of man.
How can you develop a social philosophy
before you inquire into man for himself
– regardless of the controversies about
the relationship between man for
himself and man within the community,
we will come later to this problem,
this controvery.
Whether the community perceives the
individual or the individual perceives
the community, I mean systematically,
conceptually – but however, Thomas Aquinas
was not concerned with the problem “who
is man?”, he was concerned “what is
society?” And that is the reason why
social philosophy is incomplete, because
it lacks the basic premise: knowledge
of man for himself, man in seclusion,
man communing not with the other
self, but man communing with himself.
That, only lately, Christian
philosophy began to develop.
And actually this aspect of religious
anthropology dealing with the individual.
And of course, this is what we know,
what’s known to us under the name or
the title religious existentialism,
where there are many books written
about religious existentialism.
What it is?
It means the philosophy of
man, interpreted in terms
of religious experience.
That is exactly, more or less, if we
want to simplify this equation.
However, Judaism
occupied a very unique
position in the world of religion.
While other religions stressed the
idea of God more than that of man,
Judaism, in its intellectual pursuits,
concentrated on man.
And religious anthropology
replaced, in Judaism, theology.
We have always inquired into the essence
of man, never into the essence of God.
Hence, our world formula
is quite paradoxical.
It is theocentric,
God-centered, theocentric.
However, anthropo-oriented.
We are orientated on man.
We concentrate more teleologically on
God: of course, God is the beginning
and the ultimate end of everything
– Judaism maintains that as any other
civilized religion – because if He's
not the beginning and the end of
everything, there's no need for religion.
I can never understand a religion
which becomes so modernized that
the idea of God is eliminated.
Not that the zeal or the fanaticism
makes me rebel against it, but a
simple question: if this is religion,
so there is no need to spend so
much money on its institutions.
We were, of course, we are
theocentric, but anthropo-orientated.
Of course, God is the beginning
and the ultimate end of everything.
In Him, the fullness of existence
is realized and all yearnings
of man find fulfillment.
No doubt about it.
It's very important for the
therapeutic aspect of religion.
Yet God Himself, creator of the world,
out of whose pure absolute, infinite
being, finitude emerged, God Himself
remains to us Jews, keil mistater
beshafrir chevyon: Deus absconditus,
a mysterium tremendum, a hidden God.
Inapproachable, unknowable, inexpressible, eluding the grasp of our concepts.
And if you allow me, I want here to just
call your attention to one
dichotomy, or rather to an antithesis
in our religious experience.
Our experience of God, the Judaic
experience of God – of course, I mean,
you will find it in other religions as
well, but particularly the Judaic
experience of God – is antithetic,
insofar it contains an awareness
of both: of endless remoteness
and mystery on one hand, and
of intimate closeness and
familiarity on the other hand.
Don't ask me how
it is possible, because basically
Judaism, in its approach to God, did not
operate with the Aristotelian two-valued
logic, or with the famous principle of
contradiction or the excluded middle.
Aristotle said, if it is A, it cannot
be at the same time B. If it is B,
it cannot be at the same time A.
It's either A or B. And if it's A
or B, it cannot be something else.
We say, we Jews say, typical of
our mentality, it can be A and
at the same time B. And not only
it can be A at the same time B, it
can be A and at the same time B and
also something else than A and B.
I mean, you know, ladies and
gentlemen, modern physics,
classical physics operate with it.
For instance, you know, the theory
of light is interpreted nowadays
both in terms of waves and in
terms of particles, although both
theories are mutually exclusive.
So perhaps actually the modern advanced
mathematics and advanced physics
cannot operate simply, the mass of
phenomena does not lend itself to a
two-valued logical interpretation.
The principle of contradiction and the
principle of the excluded middle
was thrown away by the scientists.
But in the religious approach,
it's certainly that we operate
with antithetic ideas, concepts.
On one hand, He is remote, on
the other hand, He is close.
In our encounter with God, we
find ourselves, many a time,
bewildered by the opposition of
two experiential alternatives.
First, as I said before,
Deus absconditus,
God who is hiding in the depths
of infinity and eternity.
And second, as the Psalmist
says, karov Hashem lechol kor'av.
The Lord is nigh unto all that
call upon Him, to all that call
upon Him in truth and sincerity.
He is both: He is nigh and
remote, He is near and far away.
This is the Jewish experience of God.
On the one hand, we experience God
as dwelling apart and beyond all
dimensions of being, hidden in the
remotest recesses of infinity, is
unapproachable and incomprehensible,
abiding in concealment, and in
the shadows of transcendence.
And the Hebrew word kadosh, holy;
whoever knows the etymological meaning
of kadosh, you know that kadosh actually
in Hebrew signifies separateness,
difference, otherness, incommensurability.
Something which doesn't
belong into this order.
Something mysterious.
It signifies the
withdrawal of God from me.
On the other hand,
the homo religiosus feels
also the immediate presence of God – His
endless remoteness and also the immediate
presence of God – outside and within him.
God is man's haven, if you
will, his fortress, his
habitation, where man resides.
He experiences God
as his companion,
father, mother, friend.
The words I'm quoting I
take it from the Bible.
The Bible is a book of the
Judaic religious experience.
Mother, friend, lover and
beloved, both together.
Who caresses his head, bent under
the load of existence, and whispers
words of condolence
and hope to him.
He is the shepherd who
cares for the helpless and the weak
and carries the young in his bosom.
This is a quotation from Isaiah.
On the one hand, Deus absconditus, on the
other hand, Deus revelatus, close God.
On one hand, mysterium
tremendum, magnum,
distant, strange, unknowable, inspiring
dread and awe, and on the other hand, Deus
revelatus, involved in creation, in every
aspect of existence, addressing Himself
to us through every twinkle of a distant
star, through every budding tree, out of
the stillness of a summer night, the cry
of the infant, and the innocent laughter
of the child, through warm thought,
feeling, strivings, and yearnings.
And on the other hand, distant,
incomprehensible, strange,
far in infinity, in
the recesses of infinity.
He confronts us both as an adversary, as
an antagonist, and as a friend.
As a stranger, and as a father.
As a familiar figure, if I may use this
expression, and as a mysterious power.
You know, Jacob, who was
wrestling with the stranger.
Who was the stranger?
If not the same God who spoke
to him the night before.
The experience is
antithetic, is dichotomous.
It's mutually exclusive, but still
these antitheses and this dichotomy
actually lend to the religious
experience its uniqueness, greatness, and
magnificence.
But of course, we must realize, keep
in mind, that while the individual homo
religiosus may engage in a paradoxical
experience – fraught with incommensurate
aspects and incongruous themes,
oscillating between complete
resignation and passionate,
ecstatic joy – the community,
the institutionalized religion must
organize its collective experience
along coherent patterns, and
cannot afford to tolerate polarity
within our religious awareness.
What is good at an esoteric
level is absolutely inoperative
at an exoteric level.
What is good for
the few individuals, for the
homines religiosi, for the great
religious genius, is absolutely
incomprehensible for the average person.
So of course, therefore, if you,
for instance, study the history
of religion, you will find that
some religions have emphasized the
aspect of remoteness of God.
And other religions on
the contrary, introduced God as familiar.
Although the religious experience,
the private religious experience
of the homo religiosus has both
motifs: the motif of remoteness
and the motif of closeness as well.
For instance, you take Christianity.
Why was the concept of Father/Son introduced?
Why?
Why was this Trinitarian motif introduced in Christianity?
Philosophically, simply, I mean, whoever
reads the literature of the Fathers
of the Desert or read the literature
of Saint by Saint Augustine, his
confessions, his God, and so forth and
on, will see that Christianity actually
was torn by two motifs: by the motif of
closeness to God and remoteness to God.
By the motif of Deus absconditus,
the hidden God, and by the motif
of Deus revelatus, the revealed
God, the one that is close to
me, who is within me, who has
intercourse with me, who is my
companion, to whom I can address
myself, I can pray, I can complain, I
may rebel, I may engage in a dialogue.
And the final result was that God the
Father is the remote one, and the Son
is the one who was walking on earth,
associating with people, speaking to them.
That's why in Christianity, in Christian
theology, you know very well, all
prayers cannot be addressed to the
Father unless we beseech the Son to
mediate between us and the Father.
Why?
Because the Father is
too remote for prayer.
Prayer cannot reach Him.
There is no way for man to
find access to God the Father.
That's why they actually simply
split divinity into two entities
and introduced the Son, who is
the God who is close to him.
Judaism, a Unitarian
religion, couldn't do that.
So in Judaism, it is an antithesis, a
dichotomy of closeness and remoteness.
Yeah.
The question is, what did
Judaism do with the problem of
its institutionalized religion?
Judaism is a private experience, it's
also an institutionalized religion.
Any religion must be institutionalized
because the word religion itself
indicates institutionalization.
Institutionalized, conceptualized, made,
so to say, available to the crowds.
Because you cannot, you see– for instance,
education, there were times when education
was considered a privilege only of the
select few, of the aristocratic society.
England had such a system.
Actually all degrees, I mean,
actually believed in aristocracy
as far as education is concerned.
You can say art, Elliot says that art is
only a product of the class of leisure.
But no one can say that religion should be
so to say, limited to the select few.
For a simple reason: because from
our viewpoint, religion saves man,
gives him salvation and redemption.
And we think that everybody is
entitled to salvation and redemption,
not only the philosopher, but the
simpleton as well, not only the
aristocrat, but the slave as well.
So you cannot turn the religious
experience into an esoteric
affair for the philosopher,
for the inquiring mind, for the
person who simply encounters God.
Means and ways must be found in order
to simplify the religious experience
and to make it available and accessible
to every prayer.
And the dichotomous religious
experience is an esoteric affair.
Esoterically, the average person in the
street cannot understand the dichotomy.
It's either or, the
principle of contradiction that
Aristotle introduced into logic
is simply it's common sense.
It's either black or white, it cannot
be between, or gray, I mean, right?
It's either
the square or a circle, it
cannot be both at the same time.
So what did Judaism do?
What motif was emphasized not
in the private experience of God,
the Judaic private experience?
The Judaic private experience, as it was
depicted and described in the Psalms,
which is the greatest book on religious
experience in general, I believe,
and I am never apologetic about it.
But it is the greatest book of the
religious experience in general.
Everybody, I think, will agree
as far as this is concerned.
The Psalmist was a religious genius,
I mean, the real homo religiosus.
In him you find Psalms, the famous Psalm,
"God is my shepherd, I shall not want."
So how is God depicted, described there?
Close, companion, my shepherd.
I associate with him, I engage
in a dialogue with him, I bend my
tired head on his shoulder, and he
whispers into me words of hope, to me.
And the same Psalmist, the next
day, the next in the next chapter
begins to speak, begins to say,
"Where can I escape from you?
Where can I find you?
I have searched you everywhere.
I found you nowhere.
I came to your temple.
I thought I'll find you
there, but you are not there.
I searched in the woods, I
didn't find your shadow. Why?
On one hand he speaks of God as his
companion and shepherd, on the other
hand, in the same breath, he says he can't
find God, he doesn't know where He is.
It's what we call numinous
presence and numinous absence.
God is present and absent.